Mashige than my sister,
put on the slump This was put by Zack, ah
, you need the slump, you'll be in
trouble if Zock
dies.  I think it's a normal year with Jean
[music]
Then when it gets
tough, I'll have to change it It's nice to be chic and happy How do I get out of
here?  There should be
[music]
written on it
[music] All
you have to do is move it voodoo It's like a
sea warrior
A man with ugly legs A man with ugly legs
Stepping on his life with his right foot A deadly murderer
A donkey who realizes his sin and suffers If you throw away your right foot  Even though it's good,
if crime and punishment are in balance, sometimes light shines in hell
Throw away your right hand
[music]
Crime and punishment are in balance
Put
that on the balance
[music]
What should I do next?
If we weigh the weight of our sins, something should happen